if you want to lose weight with a simple
low-calorie approach
then try youngevity's rev90 plan it's a
nutrient-rich
low-calorie method to controlling what
you eat and supporting your metabolism
by restricting your calorie intake at
lunch and dinner
you can help stimulate your body to
release excess energy stores and burn
excess fat
first once i lost 22 pounds health wise
i'm a new person youngevity's rev 90
pack was created to deliver the support
that you'll need when you're on a
limited calorie nutrition program
it includes our low calorie gut friendly
fit shake
that delivers 20 grams of protein per
serving in delicious chocolate or banana
cream flavors
slender fxrev further supports your body
to help it metabolize and burn its fat
stores
and we've included sleep ease with its
proprietary blend of herbs to help you
get the restful sleep that is so crucial
to successful weight loss
the rev 90 pack delivers the nutrients
you need to help stimulate the metabolic
pathways in your body
so you can achieve the weight loss you
want
you know i feel like i have me again
that i i can
have enough energy for for my family and
myself
to learn more about rev90 and the better
health challenge
contact your youngevity associate or
visit ygybetterhealth.com